[Música]
olá muito bonito mas agora ela por terem
vindo
se não fosse eu você nós também não
estaremos aqui certamente vamos então 26
ff fazer rádio há muito pouco tempo
juntos já faz rádio a a cerca de 18 anos
no rodrigo a única nenhuma - mas não
muito menos também
isso porque os bancos consideram que um
produtor rádio não faz rádio
eu trabalho chama josiane sistema pelo
média elas tanto tempo afastado e ao
mesmo tempo muita coisa meio ambiente
que está sendo praticamente igual ao
menos temos mas também faz card numa
numa área que a produção do café da
manhã e neste momento estamos os dois em
antena
das 21 às 23 em nosso papel na rádio tem
sido um um crescimento não só para nós
como também do público não está em quem
tem vindo a ouvir e que vai sempre
entrando em nosso papel no fundo é
diária
no fundo é um papel viário de
comunicação porque rádio como dizia o
fmi vai está há muito ansiava online
muito entendido comunicação com as
pessoas portanto nosso papel é de entrar
na intimidade muitas vezes as pessoas
o joel que quando está descrever o 0
fomos do antigamente com os dois
pontinhos e hora passar por cima está a
fazer rádio exemplarmente porque eu não
precisava estar aqui para obstar a
transpor na nossa cabeça a imagem do que
os fundos e toda a gente conseguiu
reconhecer certo de nossa função é se
não fazer feedback primeiro que tudo
temos uma vasta equipa de profissionais
que trabalham conosco e nós temos a
sorte de fazer um programa de
entretenimento porque rádio também tenta
em várias áreas da informação que é uma
complicação um pouco mais dura mas nós
temos a sorte de fazer entretenimento e
aquilo que nós queremos é tocar as
pessoas e o nosso papel é contar
histórias das pessoas e é o nosso papel
é olhar à nossa volta e ver o dia a dia
e transpor esse dia ia parar
fazer com que o que nosso público se
identifique é nós vivemos num equilíbrio
muito grande entre trazer uma novidade e
não terminam criando trazer a novidade
que o que nós queremos fazer é ser a voz
das pessoas que estão ouvindo coisas que
sejam vai ter o ano passado o tema que
era um pensar dentro da caixa e muitas
vezes nós temos que fazer é pensar
dentro da caixa
se eu estou a ver que toda a gente está
a dizer que está a chover
se o fla ralis é que está a chover vocês
vão ouvir realmente cachoeiro e esse é o
nosso papel é que vocês se sintam
confortáveis em casa
vamos começar aqui por um exemplo que eu
estava em casa e meu um novo nome o mais
velho ainda vou buscar pelo michael
jackson
andava ainda não tem 9 anos e um ano
passado o valor me pediu para ser
mascarada no michael jackson no flor que
acho que é uma imagem que toda a gente
tem o exemplo ea mãe deu à minha mulher
é não criando não quer encomendar uma
máscara da internet quando sua mãe rosa
seandor pesquisou pesquisa maquiagem foi
uma loja city com produção impecável
cotoco seu fez um arranjo na época eo
bernardo estava o macaé segue firme no
treino
acontece que a escola cancelou a festa
da wii no dia anterior disse é nós temos
então não vai haver festa do alumínio
primário chega a casa sem nada a ver com
minha festa de espera é amanhã mas a
rádio contar essa história não é preciso
no filho mas vai contar essa história
porque depois mais sobre essa história
não é não vai fazer queixinhas da escola
não é de que a escola cancelou a festa é
ver que as três torres maia uma máscara
de michael jackson e que não tinham e
que não foi possível usar e está à
partida parece que não é nada mas é que
vocês vão ver a seguir terça quando
começa o vídeo aqui vocês vão ver a
seguir há marcas que pagam muito
dinheiro porque o que aconteceu que não
foi combinado que não foi arranjado e só
aconteceu pela proximidade que a rádio
tem com as pessoas
[Música]
a roupa laminadas conta-nos lado
consegue descrever de outro fator mário
que a mãe fez
olha olha que coisa que eu sei nunca vai
sair no fim da tarde
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]
é que o vídeo está um pouco mais pesado
no sentido em que quando o planalto foi
a rádio com joana correia 98 vídeos em
de 20 segundos nas redes sociais passou
a efetivamente masculino bernardo passar
duas horas no fórum toca a explicar o
baixo estoque monte diante da porta por
causa do dobro na toda a gente toda a
gente saiu saiu da gestão estava
trabalhando em uma fôrma com telemóveis
e também que o que nós fizemos foi
compilar as fotos todas as manchas mas
desta vez dela nova erechim
isso não foi nada combinado e isso
acontece por causa da maioria das
pessoas
fazemos parte do grupo renascença que o
grupo de inspiração cristã e então por
isso obrigado a usar esse cheiro é um
grupo de inspiração cristã e obviamente
isso não será um caminho ou menos já
ouviram falar da história na chã do
grupo na gerência tem a mega hits fm a
rádio na agência a nissin e rádio am
já a vez da muito tempo o surto já viu a
ciência tem muita marca de inspiração
cristã como sabem como uma série de
coisas ligadas ao movimento
a igreja com o texto o passeio mais mas
também foi como sabem há muitos anos 11
veículos de comunicação para as pessoas
podem passar música da remoção que era o
sinal para as tropas avançaram entre nós
o que essa importância da revista
nacional das vezes com este papel
mobilizador não é que teve nessa altura
e hoje em dia continua e nós temos essa
presença diariamente em antena com
alguns apontamentos religiosas no
sentido não de evangelizar e ser uma
coisa muito muito presente mas passar no
fundo princípios que sejam cristãs ou
não houve qualquer outra religião devem
existir no mundo esteja da amizade o
companheirismo de partilha da vida em
comunidade no fundo preço mesmo rfa no
seu todo tem acaba por ter esse papel de
passar essa mensagem com seja com 11
programas mais específicos ou com um
apontamento então só com coisas do dia a
dia que nos tocam a todos
um exemplo aconteceu não estragar todo
natal zona de maio passado o chip
família organiza a festa de natal vai
começar uma mensagem que partilha com
esta visão não vai conhecer agora não
dava nada por aqui um diploma não vai
subir agora muito bem o resultado nós
tivemos com este vídeo também é uma
coisa continua anos
é normal porque eu vim que nos fazemos
esse terminais
achamos bem que vai pra rua partilha com
quem não tem
é no chão
é meu chão
era tchau
[Música]
o pai natal ainda frio nesta aprendi que
foi mais duas do vick certeza mais em st
seu vizinho passa a noite sozinho
já a a a
é né cara
elkann cacau já vista o tempo por
exemplo é o estudo ainda pra ela é tão
renatão já é na cama é é natal
miguel diz que deve estar a sonhar se
acha que não vai ajudar que os natal
feliz natal e chuva a tua mulher
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]
isto é com esta atitude mais brincalhona
e até bastante j
confirmo aqui passar a mensagem de
família de partilha de solidariedade de
machismo é de quando escrevia estava
atracado na minha papel das câmeras
letras eu pensei o que se passa em minha
casa e passei minha casa desde que eu
cheguei a ver uma percentagem vai fazer
tudo
infelizmente ao longo dos anos fui muito
que minha mãe foi conseguindo ganhar e
ainda vai pronto então são essas coisas
que nós fazemos a nossa vida pessoal
fomos aqui eu acho que toda a gente se
identifica com isto este esteve também
têm estas componentes todas cantora que
está à frente também a componente de
podermos mostrar e aproximar as vezes
ditas convidamos também para participar
conosco e sabemos que as pessoas também
gostam de ver essa proximidade é essa
até a partilha como que existe nas
equipas para ser nunca nenhum exemplo
não é de uma empresa funciona ver um
caso de imprudência como é que nós todos
os funcionários e convidados depois
também uma série de termos tudo narrado
existe um grupo que é o cordão da
amizade que faz um alguma solidariedade
seja com instituições seja com juntas de
freguesia
neste vídeo aqui também para juntar
tanta gente numa sala
convidamos já menti com 3021 que são
ajudados também por esta por esta razão
da amizade que existe né
lá não romper como importante foi o
mundial que uma uma simbiose da mensagem
que nós queremos passar através da
trilha incidental família portuguesa
uma coisa é certa já começaram a chegar
a nada
hoje wilson não ficava ninguém
estudamos volta a espanha tanto foi uma
gráfica foi magnífica até bichos tiver
tento foi vendo os vídeos ficarão tudo
conheço em que as festas de natal nas
escolas das inscrições dos grupos foram
ao som da nossa música e com
coreografias feitas a pensar em mim e na
mensagem que nós fizemos aqui no top
inspirada na que eu tenho vai da união
dois períodos nunca nem por todo o país
e quiseram mais ou menos criar da forma
legal que obriga à frente olha olha que
não foi pra galera a mensagem da
propaganda
[Música]
e foi isso foi um dos vídeos nós pois
continuamos a receber mais vídeos e
fizemos uma segunda versão de steve como
escolas mas obviamente não vamos passar
aqui porque a idéia já está já estava
perdida é e queria reforçar o nosso
papel de proximidade com as pessoas
lembram agora um vídeo que nós não
trazemos também não vale a pena mostrar
uma espingarda com o dia da criança
e eu quando quando estávamos a pensar
num vídeo primeira criança tive uma
idéia e pensar no que é que não quer que
os problemas que eu tenho em casa como
nunca vai lavar os dentes por mais que
eu diga até que os dentes já foi não
fosse eu tô vendo não fosse eu vá eu
chegava à escola chegava da escola dizer
que batiam no requer por comida do nepal
e ainda por mais um ano passado foi um
ano muito bom em termos de mensagem anti
bullying
então eu fiz uma uma vez que vemos uma
letra pensava em uma coisa que para
transmitir essas essas mensagens todas e
eu pensei eu vou precisar de um grupo de
crianças para cantar vou querer um grupo
de crianças para lançá lá e conseguir
realizar contatos e essas coisas são
sempre foi contra o tempo e então eu
achei o contato de um do maestro que tem
um grupo de crianças para cantar ia
viajar ele envia um e mail a dizer ter
invertido a esta música é também para
ele entretanto envolve uma chamada
estava num ensaio produto enquanto é que
quando é que vão pagar e hoje só lamento
mas não tem orçamento é perfeitamente
compreendida foi também o próprio também
sou músico não para uma justiça não vou
tocar mas isso é uma coisa diferente
lamento que não quero participar ou não
querem participar no encerramento que
não quer participar é muito obrigado
tempo dependendo passado cinco minutos
tocando estufa através da liga dizer
parte culpa e agora no seu e maio eu
quero que as minhas crianças passam para
desta mensagem às crianças gostarem
contem com elas e isto é é que o que eu
sinto que rádio enfrentou dos outros
mais é que nós conseguimos mesmo tocar
as pessoas
não sei porque não sei como mas esse é o
nosso papel é isso que nós fazemos
tentamos fazer o melhor possível todos
os livros diariamente estamos presentes
em muitas ocasiões da vida das pessoas
e nós também estamos no cilada e quando
estava no café da manhã e ao programa e
mais tempo para tomar o pequeno-almoço e
havia uma rapariga distribuir jornal
metro na rua está ali desde bem cedo e
ao passarmos surgiu a idéia da festa
parecia fácil para alencar que acha as
instalações da manhã começaram a
distribuir jornais estão tão cedo então
eu faça chuva ou faça sol sempre
construímos lá ela estava lá e todos
vivos moram fundir o banco já conhecidos
as pessoas passavam mim e diziam de bom
dia e surgiu a idéia de como é que esta
camisa dando aquela lenda que ela vem eo
trem começa a cavar e vai descobrir onde
é que vem é sandra
sandra foi um problema declarou
guerrinha sandra os pais de sandra não
criou no não têm telemóvel foi o que se
for preciso eu aceitava trabalhar no
porto encontra-se a 15 à internet
governada há 20 anos e no fundo aquilo
que nós proporcionamos a sandra
fui fã foi uma materialização que essa
era uma pessoa de carne e osso que nós
tocamos e eu vamos fazer aquilo que
vocês vão ver é que nós tentamos fazer
todos os dias através da cadeia que o
vosso dia seja o melhor possível e que
vocês sintam contente com o nosso papel
porque muitas vezes nós passamos os dias
a trabalhar e sentindo que ninguém dá o
devido valor e à mentira porque há
sempre alguém ver o nosso trabalho
provei para o mal mas há sempre alguém
ver o nosso trabalho e às vezes não
dizem sócio
[Música]
mas passar às finais hoje vai ser um dia
de congresso que acha nib fogo
esperam-se desfilar no livro que une a
sofrer gols vai ficar aqui no seu lugar
[Música]
vamos aonde iremos leite alexandre
relvas se destrói participantes
não só em toda a zona euro falou ah
a o chamo espeche o meu me levar o teste
que o seu prato preferido é bacana
ronaldo sou eu imaginei estivesse ali
uma camisola do fogo for autografada
pelos jogadores
[Música]
bem vindos ao buscar eu mudo perfumes
xampus e alegrias em trair
[Música]
um dos agentes ao tubo e eu sei como é
que estava em toronto
assim surpreendida cujo preço é firme e
acerto entre o começo
ae
não quero internet
a uefa xóóóra não olha aproveitarei
[Música]
agora protecçom eu não sei eu tava
achando que ela precisa um sonho de
querer e acordar estava
ae
[Música]
aranda e vou pegando ganha enfrentar
saddam e ouvi dizer que o prejuízo não
conseguir ainda mais a carreira estou
querendo agir a não ser visto nas
funções de manhã é é isso
foi um dia que temos de enfrentar sandra
e ea nós também é nós também sabemos que
o povo - esperamos que todos os dias
consigamos dar um dia em frente a
câmeras ou às vezes porque nas coisas
pequenas palavras que dizem que tocam
direito em a pessoa que ela pensa que só
aceita falar comigo é só para concluir
uma assentada está quase a acabar para o
nosso papel porque a rádio vai vai
evoluindo ao longo dos anos e apesar de
continuarmos a transmitir pelo usuário
a internet é uma componente muito forte
do nosso trabalho e para o nosso papel
mais técnico é estarmos atentos às novas
formas de fazer chegar a nossa mensagem
porque está o fim do dia é tudo para
passar a nossa mensagem e devo dizer que
estes estão completamente desatualizados
no dia em que vivemos numa era nova do
cinema mudo e as pessoas consomem estes
conteúdos têm sono facebook este vídeo
não está todos os mandados foram passar
um ano
hoje em dia se você estiver em preparar
conteúdos que não estou a ver a minha
mas conteúdo da internet legenda em tudo
porque assim como está e alegar
transferir a brigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]